hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to baldies unreal
basics in education and learning now
someone have a great idea and burn the
whole school down that was awesome it
needed to go away all these unreal
multiplayer could be a possibility oh
that's what that was all about okay well
I don't even multiple air just yet I
need to get a life and beat this game
that's what I'm gonna do and that's how
I feel about this so I'm gonna do that
and I'm gonna have a great time doing it
right I'm stalling enough to play this
now I don't know what the new mechanic
is but I'm sure it'll be fine
Chapter three forget well this is
beautiful but why is it beautiful I
don't think that this is comes out right
here Oh God Oh No
wait a minute hang on a second how many
times do I need to run away from this
goddamn school Oh No well here I go
waddle in my way down the halls I'm here
to burn the place down salad oh no not
so low [ __ ] oh hey how you doing why am
i back here why would I be back here
this looks like as many years after the
events of Baldy Oh best friends forever
jump rope girl
baldy baldy baldy i'm much shorter now
this is true to life now Baldy hey Baldy
how are you doing there Baldy hey Baldy
what are you doing Baldy hey Baldy Baldy
oh this fortnight Baldy would have if
you got there buddy bully would chew
okay all right I'm just gonna leave now
Baldy
you're busy obviously I'm just gonna
waddle my way out the door see ya don't
let the door hit you where the ass bit
yeah oh hey jump rope girl don't know if
you ever had a real name how are you
doing good to see ya
how's the family how's
[Music]
I was that good hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey oh [ __ ]
okay oh god no oh holy [ __ ] okay hard
pass hard pass Baldy hard Oh God hard
pass Oh hard pass oh good a playground
what exactly am I forgetting
am I forgetting like my childhood am I
forgetting like someone I knew and
childhood am I forgetting about my
parents I'm forgetting about some
horrible traumatic experience or just
like school that I didn't like to go to
yeah probably one not the other right
okay whatever
let's not hey oh all the if you could
just stay as far away from me as you
possibly could I'd greatly appreciate it
same goes for you jumper opal girl maybe
I'm trying to forget about you
someone unzipping their fly kind of
Santa Fe was that okay alright I got bad
that's good I feel good about that I'm
guessing that it's just a series of
glowing white balls that I need to Ram
my face into and hopefully I'll forget
something if I do that if I smash my
head into as many white balls as I
possibly can
I'm bound to forget something oh [ __ ] my
god yeah yeah what's wrong with your
eyes
[Music]
okay all right where I don't know where
I am I don't know where you are I don't
know what you are but you go away I'm
not gonna have enough time to run away
from you I don't know where all these
memories are I know they had dime
pillars of light in the sky but I'm
Delta view that's not gonna help me okay
I'm definitely not gonna have enough
time to get away from Baldy cuz I know
for a fact that after I get all six even
if I do which I probably won't I'm gonna
have to run back to the beginning orna
hey Baldy how about you don't get faster
just throwing that out there
that's an option if you if you want that
option hey I took the wrong way to go
okay
hey you doing hey Baldy can you turn the
light bulbs out of your eyes and just
stop chasing me my eyes are up here
stop staring up my ass stop staring up
my ass and stop staring at my ass I got
stopped talking about my ass so much
it's like the only thing I ever
mentioned about myself in these games
this is how much my ass gets slapped by
Baldy and that's never something the
it's not a point point of conversation
so since I don't know I'm shouting that
at you but to stop to stop looking at my
ass okay where's that other one over
there okay well I'm not gonna make that
all right cool
well this is great hey Baldy oh [ __ ] oh
you fast you faster you look faster you
lose some weight where's your slaps oh
sure sure that's real fast okay well um
hmm yeah yes
okay all right I got it I got it hmm
oh [ __ ] no no not like this okay no hang
on fire bad
fire bad okay all right okay we I don't
think I'm gonna make it there's a beach
ball don't know why that hasn't popped
yet I think it's hot enough in here to
roast a beach ball okay whatever huh all
my fire drill training is so mean that I
need to stop drop and roll at this point
but I'm not stopping I'm not dropping
and I'm not rolling how do I stop drop
and roll
oh okay could I stop it lock it
pop it and drop it maybe that's always
an option
okay whatever hey wait no wait wait wait
a minute wait I guess it's fine I guess
that's fine okay this is fine this is
fine this is fine this is fine I just
burned my nipples off but that's fine
come on hurry
okay I'm gonna make it I think I think
I'm hey I forgot I forgot it all ooh
yeah all right great I'm so happy
haha yeah oh boy why did I do that oh
[ __ ]
okay well that was I mean not easier
than I expected but that was just about
as as I expected but let's there's one
more here and I want to give it a try
just because I don't think it's a
separate chapter so it's probably not
deserving of its own video so I'm gonna
play Arcade Mode summer camp survive for
as long as you can while Baldy expects
you to keep fire or going a fine
scattered firewood avoid bear traps and
keep holy happy yeah baby remember what
you're doing
[Music]
okay you got it Baldy
you got you got it you god I got four
pieces of food I don't know how I'm
gonna be able to see bear traps in this
grass but okay Wow indeed I don't get a
score the Sun what's that glowing white
in the distance I'm gonna find out what
that is Baldy oh that's normal
yeah I definitely expect to see a soda
machine a school desk and a locker
sitting in the middle oh no no what are
you doing out here friend friend friend
friend
oh god friend you okay buddy buddy buddy
pal what are you doing buddy what are
you doing out here
okay well oh there is points oh okay
there's points oh the fire is about to
go out I shouldn't come over here well
you know c'est la vie c'est la Bleu
c'est la Bleu I don't see any bear traps
I'm sorry let this doggy I've got no
excuses at this point just comes job
listen Baldy listen listen listen listen
listen listen listen listen listen
listen listen listen
[Music]
Wow I sure did it I did it I'm proud of
that all right there we have it all done
goody goody gumdrops I did it there's
one thing I did it was it and I did it
leave it at that this chapter is not
available yet which frankly for the best
so thank you everybody so much for
watching until the next part is released
I will lay this to rest and then Baldy
can rest until the official sequel comes
out whenever that will come out so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you
[Music]